[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
oh
paul bocuse call magnifique poisson
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire et
bien ce poisson c'est un bar ou alors
chez nous dans le midi c'est un loup
dans le maine à peu près on va le faire
un groupe c'est à dire convaincus à ce
poisson ou milieu d'une pâte feuilletée
ou d'une part site tout son arôme c'est
à dire que seul où il va être farsi
d'herbe
il va y avoir un peu de persil du persil
estragon oui on va donc enlever la peau
et attention quand vous avez un loup
comme ça il faut toujours toujours
garder la peau avec les écailles
je vous fais voir tout à l'heure c'est
beaucoup plus facile à enlever la peau
quand t es caillis on a bon très bien
donc pas et cahiers alors rien de neuf
pour la dorure ont un peu de sel un
petit peu de fromage blanc un petit peu
d'épinards du beurre un peu de farine
pour son projet la table de l'huile
d'olive mais attention de l'huile
d'olive avec un peu ragot un peu de
romarin et un peu de sauge toujours
l'assaut du vinaigre de vin toujours du
vinaigre de vin parce qu'on va faire un
petit beurre oger d'après et du vin
blanc sec un peu par exemple d'un peu de
pouilly et et attendez on n'a pas mangé
que ça après qu'est ce qu'elle vous
servez avec quoi accompagner le bien le
servir avec une entrecôte à l'échalote
alors autre goût d'aller au bout oui et
puis et puis on fait une cervelle de
canut qui est un fromage blanc battu
avec des herbes parce qu'on est
amplement désherbe et avec ça on va
faire des oeufs à la neige
oui eh bien je pense qu'on devrait
partir voir ou specht les loups les bars
vous croyez pas allons-y gaiement
fallait à la pêche
les pêcheurs professionnels de notre
région de pêche de plusieurs manières à
la palombe
c'est une ligne qui peut faire 200
mètres à plusieurs kilomètres de long
avec quelques centaines d'âmes sont ils
sont et chez de gravette ou ou dude
amorce pour le bar ils sont les pauses
et henry sont déposés en mer des heures
de marin il relevé lendemain ou cinq six
heures ou huit ou dix huit heures après
la deuxième manière qui est c'est de se
promener une vitesse extrêmement réduite
et le pêcheur professionnel de chaque
côté de son bateau à des ligues montée
ils pêchent le bar dans les courants à
quelques cents à quelques mètres du fond
je crois que c'est là c'est le résultat
de cette pêche là donnent le meilleur
pressante à dire que le poisson meurt à
l'air libre
la plupart du temps par éclatement de la
vessie natatoire natatoire etc je crois
que c'est ça confère aux poissons une
qualité extraordinaire pêcheurs
professionnels pratiquent également une
pêche au chalut ces poissons là nous le
remarquons nous les professionnels
restent les cuisiniers par leur aspect
leur aspect fade et il est il va de soi
que ça dégrade encore une fois la
noblesse de ce poisson fort recherché
pour sa consommation sur cette table
vous voyez un assortiment de poissons
pêchés par des petits bateaux
particulièrement pêcher à la ligne
ce canton est particulièrement destiné à
une clientèle de restaurateurs parce que
indiscutablement il est plus cher que le
poisson 2
mais la qualité j'ai aussi nettement
supérieur il se caractérise se
caractérise par un brillant contre que
n'ont pas les autres poissons
une fermeté de la chair et dans
l'ensemble nous avons facilement preneur
au site pour ses articles
ce poisson est pêché par les petits
bateaux qui sort le matin qui rentrent
le soir qui pêchent dans les fonds
côtier parmi les rochers
donc ce poisson a vu en principe entre
24 à 36 heures au maximum de mer il ya
un problème de pâtes
ah oui là poids vous pas un problème et
pour certaines il ya dans la mare si la
ménagère ou la cuisinière s'est fait une
pub paye t elle fait à peu près 700
grammes de pâte feuilletée ou de pâte
brisée parce que je pense qu'une pâte
brisée
ça peut faire la même chose mais enfin
une femme formule qui est beaucoup plus
facile
je veux maintenant que beaucoup de
grands magasins de grandes surfaces
vendent de la pâte prête à cuire ils
vont des pâtes feuilletées prêtes à
cuire savoir se sont faites au beurre ça
j'en suis pas sûr mais enfin on peut
toujours les gestions pâtissier elle
participe euros m 700 grammes de
feuilletage alors cette ça c'est un
poisson pour combien de personnes il
fait un peu près pour quatre à cinq
personnes
et si la pâte il faut acheter combien de
grammes près 700 grammes de pâtes 700 g
non maintenant on va passer aux
l'épluchage du loup du bav mais qu'on
est avec le bar alors j'ai bien dit pour
reconnaître un poisson frais il faut
qu'ils aient l'oeil très vif laverie
comme vous les cailles ou très brillante
qui soit envoyé en corse en gagnant et
les huîtres et rouge mais là on les a
déjà enlevé alors on va procéder pour
enlever la poêle dans la poule b la peau
c'est assez facile il vous faut un petit
couteau ça on peut y en avoir
alors on part de la tête
voyez la voilà à vous enlever la une
fente et puis là vous commencez à le
détacher
vous avez la peau bien sûr que c'était
un travail mais enfin il ya une formule
vous avez les poissonniers ils sont ils
semblent relever les peaux alors je
pense le mieux c'est faire enlever la
peau par son poissonnier
mais vous vous préférez qu'on ne pourra
son reste avec sa peau jusqu'aux d'année
oui parce que c'est comme un gibier
c'est comme un lièvre quand on enlève la
peau d'animaux et bien c'est bien mieux
le peu de goût
et oui et puis vous savez les chinois
disent toujours la peau les os la viande
mais là la peau va pas s'en servir
non pour moi quand on fait un poisson
meunière j'aime bien qu'on laisse la
peau qui vous savez je vous dire ainsi
la ménagère peut pas enlever la peau
elle la laisse et puis à l'école qu'on
pressent donc là pour restera et la peau
donne du goût contrairement à ce qu'on
croit la peau du poisson c'est très très
bon envoyez j'enlève la peau c'est très
facile
attention ne pas couper l'eau dit pas
c'est pas bon on dit quelquefois que
c'est lourd à digérer c'est pas plus
lourd qu'autre chose les gens élisent
celle où quand ils commencent à voir
manger une livre des poissons qui
mangent la peau derrière l'en bien sûr
que c'est lourd alors là on enlève les
deux côtés ah oui oui la peau louvoyer
la fraîcheur du poisson c'est très
important avec la fraîcheur du poisson
c'est là il est pour technicolor et rose
rouge
voilà la peau est tombé à l'envoyer ça a
été facile puisque les écoles sont là et
ça paye les soeurs et de l'autre côté on
procède donc au même rv et on va enlever
l'art est là l'arête dorsale qui est là
et dans 7 à la place de l'art est qu'on
va y bourré interne
là vous commencez à ça et on va mettre
le cerfeuil dedans d'abord on va le salé
on va salle est là au milieu bien ça les
données brême le provost et ribes le mot
jeune femme dont je me sers de mayence
est bien pour moi
là on va bourrer les graines de les
feuilles d'estragon bien dans la cenc
merci voyez des beauty bout du cerfeuil
voilà impeccable et maintenant on va
hambourg et on apprend le
on va le mettre là dessus pour 120 bus
qu'on fait voilà le loup est là et la
balmette la maintenant veulent ça l'est
à l'intérieur le poivre et aussi du coup
de poivre là encore et on va faire une
petite préparation d'épinards et fromage
blanc vous expliquer à quoi ça sert de
masque blanc est maigre
il n'est pas le problème le problème
qu'on y met une farce humide parce que
finalement ça c'est une farce humide
l'épinard est très humide le fromage
blanc est très humide au poivre parce
que ça donne un goût aux salles et on
met ça l'intérieur de loups pourquoi
commence à l'interview du loup c'est à
dire que quand le loup va cuire dans sa
patte ça va faire de la vapeur et ça va
m'empêcher de loup soit sec
vous savez il ya même certains ménagères
dans certaines régions qui bourre de
fromage blanc certaines volailles
donc ça le même principe et vous avez de
l'épinard du fromage blanc c'est pas mal
on pourrait y mettre de la crème et moi
je préfère le fromage blanc c'est plus
noble dans la bourrée de farce bien beau
être face à peut-être un petit peu trop
mais enfin notre graal est mal vu passer
le temps il est gros voilà ça c'est bon
et maintenant voilà et maintenant on va
le faire ça les deux suspects ont avoué
et on va le faire mariner un peu avec
cette huile de livres où il ya le thym
le laurier toutes les aires d toutes les
herbes et alors là on fait mariner alors
combien de temps là aussi on peut faire
ça la veille
rahhaoui envoyé on laisse là et on va le
mettre de côté et même goût vrai nom on
peut mais enfin pour le moment on va le
faire tout de suite oui mais nous si on
le fait la beille oui vous le court et
vous le mettez dans un papier cellophane
et vous leur mettez dans votre glacière
ou dans votre réfrigérateur selon ce que
vous avez à la maintenant faire place
nette
tu viens passer le feuilletage le
feuilletage savez c'est la porte
voilà si oui très très bien et puis
l'autre aussi va pendant que j'en ai
fait deux alors donc si vous voulez je
les ai fait un peu à l'avant parce que
un jour peut-être qu'on fera une
démonstration au feuilletage oh oui
j'aimerais bien c'est très difficile à
faire
voilà alors voilà elles ont donc si vous
voulez on va faire pour poser le loup le
bar dessous alors voilà il doit y aura
aussi une plaque à pâtisserie pas là
voilà voilà
oui attention je peux être chaud et puis
vous allez me labrie un petit peu on
aimerait voir pleurer comme ça bien
c'est pas tellement de beurre la farine
mais il faut pas trop hein parce que
faut juste que ça soit beurré ya non
seulement tout voilà on va bien et tant
que cette porte là
fall a très bien un peu comme
auriez-vous fait un show pour mettre
pour poser votre poisson dessus un ça va
quand vous tenez un rouleau pour bien
étendre de la pâte faut pas tenir leur
lot ici parce que si vous le tenez ici
vous allez vous pouvez pas diriger votre
lot il faut toujours tenir un rouleau
sur les beaux arts
oui parce que vous dirigez votre souvent
pas toujours été mince maintenant voilà
notre salle à et on va amener notre
poisson un oui et on va le faire glisser
là sans trop d'huile
mais voilà il est posé la montre et là
on va leur mettre de côté il va attendre
encore un petit moment là tranquillement
on peut enlever ça c'est fini pour nous
c'est fini
oui et maintenant vais tendre l'autre
deuxième pâte qu'elle a alors donc ça
c'est du feuilletage qui était mis à six
tours vous savez que le feuilletage ces
deux là c'est une des 30
et dans cet étang on y incorpore du
beurre c'est à dire que ça fasse très
très fute faut faire attention que le
foutoir choain une fois un show au moins
à 220 très chaud très très ce week-end
au départ saisir la pâte et après on
baisse la température quand il est à 250
on a le poids sont là le saisir c'est à
dire qu'on va le saisir à peu près
pendant 10 minutes
pascal poisson comme ça il va cuire 40
minutes ah bon alors dix minutes à four
très chaud pour les travaux de baisse à
combien eh bien vous baissez à peu près
à 160 pour que votre poisson continue de
pochettes un bon alors là vous étendez
marin le dessous il ya pas d'importance
classement un peu épais mais là vous
attendez très minces c'est là est
beaucoup plus mal que les autres à ce
que la pâte faut que ça soit mais le
feuilletage voilà
vous faites de langres cloud et donc
vous le disiez tout dans le marbre ça va
bien pour moi je préfère le bois oui ah
oui le bois c'est bien plus merveilleux
que le marbre pour travailler en cuisine
enfin l'union nous pose vous voyez on a
peut-être un petit peu trop là j'ai vu
un peu grand
bon alors là vous amener le poisson la
pso et maintenant c'est simple on va
mettre le don qu'il était sale elle été
poivré et tout près tout pour
assaisonner on met dessus et la voyez
vous voulez bien votre poisson comme ça
et on fait un petit bord du oui à temps
mais on va garder un peu de pâte voulait
me dire il ya trois fermes on va garder
un peu de la patte tout est tendu tout
poète pour faire un petit peu là alors
donc la fois la forme du poisson et donc
il va zy va se coller et là maintenant
on va découper le poisson
or le poisson il découpe comme ça ici
qui on va lui mettre une petite
nageoires safra jolie nageoires là on va
faire revenir ici ici et puis on va lui
faire une queue non poissons à nager la
ligue là allez on va lui en faire une
autre petite tient les safaris il est
irrégulier il est donc la pâte
là j'ai pas mal fini on va lui faire un
oeil pour que ça soit un poisson
intelligent clean et de là il même voilà
donc voyez votre poisson il a commencé à
prendre forme dans la gare non mais on
peut la garder pour faire des
sacristains on peut le garder pour faire
autre chose que qui dépose un peu long
mais ça ne fait rien on peut mettre une
pièce c'est bien mais maintenant on va
le mais il est bientôt sept bouts mais
pour m doré vous vous y attendez on va
lui faire d'abord une lui faire le la
tête attendait donc hasselhoff pour le
dos et le relais de rue
love 7 à 9 ans tient on l'adoré c'est au
sale dort mieux
alors non on l'appelle voyez donc on
mélange et la voilà et on dort un peu
une première couche gens là bien doré un
faux pas va pas durer comme il faut
alors là on va lui faire le têt et
emblématique citoyens comme l'iphone
jolie bouche il va vous sourire il est
heureux regardez c'est qu'ils ont valu
faire un peu de nageoires là ça n'aille
pas trop loin alors on va les faire un
peu de trucs sur la queue et puis dans
le bon il manque qu il manque les
écailles un oui alors les écailles
finalement va les faire les voyez c'est
facile d'une douille avec un rond amélie
ont fait les écrire le voyou fête des
écoles tout le long la facile et puis on
va les mettre à cuire les pipolo qui va
cuire je pense qu'on va faire un petit
beurre un petit beurre aux herbes
parce que ce loup comme ça ça va être un
peu sec et si on fait un petit beurre
aux herbes
vous verrez sera pas mal et fizi très
facile y a pas besoin d'eux show du
beurre bien sûr oui je vois où le four
allait continuer à bien doré 1
voilà des câbles bon là c'est pas bien
fait là en bon rang les hommes avaient
étonné voilà bon allez on va le mettre
dans le four de la médisance nancy va on
a peut-être fait trop long mais
peut-être même pas rentrer aussi au
formidable
alors là maintenant on va le mettre au
four eh bien on va faire la petite sauce
aux herbes une petite sauce au beurre et
on enchaîne un petit peu un petit peu
d'échalotes c'est à dire que l'échalote
pour moi l'échalote surtout les chaudes
grise c'est ce qu'il ya de meilleur pour
le poisson avec l'échalote on fait tout
avec l'échalote et un poisson sans
échalotes
c'est très triste on parle pas avant la
noce d'échalotes hachées
on va faire nos équipes pour aller on va
enlever le str à gond là un petit peu
d'estragon et moi j'aime les herbes
hachées pas trop fine
parce que quand on mange trop faim ça
perd son bout ça perd toute sa qualité
un petit peu de chefs fait un petit peu
de persil à et moi j'aime le piercing et
pas friser parce que je trouve le persil
nos frisé de meilleur goût voilà et là
on va chercher grossièrement c'est à
dire sans trop de problèmes en chef un
j'aime pas une cheminée ça m'arrange
voilà
envoyez-les aux herbes sont hachées
voilà et pour aller plus vite
au lieu de prendre une casserole
ordinaire j'ai pris une poêle vous allez
voir la raison c'est à dire que je mets
toutes mes herbes là dedans avec
l'échalote l'estragon le cerfeuil et là
le poivre c'est à dire qu'on va faire
une petite réduction de vin blanc et de
vinaigre amber nantais tout dire non
c'est pas un donnant presque un an
qu'ils connaissent pas l'estragon
alors le vin blanc n'ont alors rien le
vin blanc et vert il faut bien il faut
bien car oui puis on regarde le reste
pour boire avec le poisson est un petit
peu de vinaigre de vin voilà et là
maintenant on va mettre réduire ça à
grand galop a fait très chaud très très
grand galop et vous pensez pas qu'on
aurait peut-être aller voir ce que fait
notre loup maintenant
oui mais heureusement que je les
couverts d'un papier parce que si je
vous avais entendu de le surveiller
il serait noir je vous ai dit les dorées
à point alors on avait dit pas encore
aussi ans il a vécu à la voyez le
feuilletage à développer mais un donc le
loup est bien dorée à l'intérieur il est
cuit et sa boussole
ah oui voilà déjà on peut le remettre au
foie aussi boulet alors là maintenant
c'est fini le réduire
je mets une pincée de sel un petit pain
c est pour remplacer le binaire qui a
complètement réduit et où je rajoute un
tout petit peu d'eau voilà comme ça et
maintenant je vais attendre que ça
reboux une fois tout est froide où je
pars elle est là maintenant je m'en vais
mettre mon bord vous voyez on va en
mettre à peu près pour quatre personnes
l'envoyer pour faire un bord qu'ils
soient bien liés il faut bien que ça
bout dans la poêle et vous prenez votre
bord voiliers qui est très mou 6 heures
du président r c'est pas possible
là vous mettez votre beurre alors on est
bien d'accord et il faut que ça soit
réduit à glace à varen et là maintenant
vous laissez bouillir et vous allez voir
il va se produire un phénomène savas
émulsionner quand il est chaud attention
pour vous voler et donc vous voyez là
maintenant le borgne bouillir bouillie à
bouillir et ça va se lier et donc ça va
vous faire une sauce aux herbes ou il ya
ni farine niehoff il a uniquement du
beurre réduction de vin blanc réduction
de vinaigre les chats l'eau le sel le
poivre a toujours et toujours maître du
poivre au dernier moment parce que le
poids moins sincère et ça cuit et du
poivre en grains et moi je préfère le
poivre noir c'est peut-être pas bien
jolie dans une sauce et c'est doublement
meilleur envoyez votre source qui ces
mules sione et qui se lit tout le sol et
elle se lit tout seul parce que votre
beurre n'était pas froid si votre beurre
avait été très froid votre saut serait
déjà toutes tournées il y aurait d'un
côté du beurre clarifié n'irai pas une
sauce loyers qui seraient liés voyez
comme ils se lient là il était déjà à
tout préparer
comment il fallait quand même le
chauffer le beurre il a tellement vous
voyez en 2000 c'est bon aulas a prévu
d'écourter votre loup 1
vous enlevez vous allez voir jouer pour
rester là parce qu'après ça fout le camp
où je suis obligé tout faire voilà et
voilà votre bord voyez votre beurre
comme il est lié voilà voilà
alors pour conserver le loup c'est
facile alors beaucoup pays si vous me
dites vous enlevez carrément la calotte
là est bien prêt voulait couper comme un
poisson ordinaire bien sûr il y en a qui
vont dire pourquoi qui laisse l'arrêtent
pas ce qu'on pourrait couper comme ça et
coupé des temps je laisse l'arête c'est
comme dans une viande il faut toujours
que poisson cuit avec son art est une
côte d'agneau c'est bien meilleur qu une
noisette de la parfumerie
voilà donc vous avez votre poisson voyez
cuit impeccable voilà alors après vous
couper à chacun un petit bout attention
ne pas vous brûler c'est chaud là voyez
il ya toutes les herbes comparé fumer là
voilà après dans l'assiette ou mettez le
morceau de poisson et vous n'appelez de
beurre fondu
vous savez ce beurre fondu la certitude
de servir 6-3 6-1 peut servir qui pour
une russe à peu sa mire pour tous pour
un merlin
tous les poissons pêchés
[Musique]